un peu prise en otage par eric ciotti et
l'électorat qui représente on n'est pas
certain de sa sincérité pour l'instant
il faut oublier que valérie pécresse
avait quand même quitté les républicains
en disant que laurent wauquiez qui est
d'ailleurs le grand perdant de cette
semaine de cette primaire a radicalisé
la droite qu'il avait trop à droite
maintenant elle est obligée quelques
années après de venir sur ses marchés
ses plates-bandes et de dire la même
chose que ce qu'ils disaient qu'elle lui
reprocher de dire mais je crois que
c'est tout le problème de la sincérité
et aussi de l'incarnation de cette
droite là parce que on préféra toujours
l'original à la copie et beaucoup
d'électeurs militants qui ont voté pour
la mouvance sioniste eux vont sans doute
si jamais valérie pécresse dérives trop
vers le centre droit préféré aller voir
eric zemmour si sa campagne prend et
qu'il va réussir à la lancer quelque
chose est clairement déjà au sein des
républicains la fracture est là
guillaume pelletier monsieur pernaut qui
ont dit voilà le discours de zemmour
nous fait vibrer et se font exclure le
lendemain parce qu'ils ont osé dire que
ce discours là les séduisait donc il ya
une cassure profonde valérie pécresse va
tout faire pour ne pas la montrer pour
ne pas la mettre en scène mais les
réelles et ça va être difficile pour
elle d'avoir une stratégie crédible
alors qu'elle avait quitté ce parti
parce qu'ils étaient trop à droite et
d'incarner une ligne de droite dure
alors qu'il ya une offre de droite dure
beaucoup plus forte du côté d'eric
zemmour c'est vrai pression sur lyon
pelletier qui l'a pas été exclu mais
qu'il a été déchargé de son sa
vice-présidence des républicains pour a
déclaré ça et que guillaume pelletier
est assez coutumier du fait c'est pour
ça qu'on le surnomme d'ailleurs le
variant français voient la tendance à
passer d'un camp à l'autre de manière
assez leste avec le même
s'adossant qualité